interactions entre des yvelinois des
essonniens des populations de pays
africains
c'est le thème de cette exposition
organisée par les deux collectivités
une exposition pour présenter leurs
actions de solidarité internationale
menée en afrique une politique porté par
le département des yvelines depuis plus
de 10 ans à travers son réseau
d'associations
nous avons à essaie d'étendre cette
envie d'être solidaire du monde a de
plus en plus de personnes de plus en
plus d'associations a de plus en plus de
collectivités locales
je crois que ta véritable enjeu donc
expliquer convaincre et faire que
d'autres s'engagent voilà le but de
cette exposition
cette exposition elle est construite
autour de portraits des portraits dit
binois des portraits des soignants qui
sont présents dans des associations dans
des collectivités locales dans des
entreprises qui ont décidé un jour de
s'engager dans une action de coopération
internationale parmi ces portraits
hélène giraud présidente de solidarité
and in france and hum le nom d'un
village situé au sénégal soutenu par le
département des yvelines cette
association basée à plaisir mène des
projets d'éducation de santé et d'agro
écologie dans cette commune sénégalaise
d'un village en brousse très une zone
très défavorisé mais où les gens ont
envie de faire plein de choses toujours
le sourire et ce sont vraiment des liens
d'amitié qui m'ont donné envie de
continuer à les aider et de créer cette
association alphabétisation des femmes
développement de périmètres maraîchers
des programmes en cours de réalisation
ces initiatives sont exposées jusqu'au
29 avril au domaine de madame elisabeth
prochaine étape place de la tour à
houdan à partir du 1er mai